auf jeden Fall eine gute Sache wenn du
studierst am Ende hast du einen sicheren
Job und dann geht's dir gut halt ne dann
brauchst du nicht irgendwie da zu
kämpfen dann Job du bist Ingenieur und
dann hast du ein anderes Leben Musik
Parodien haben wir angefangen spontan
das war ganz spontaner irgendwie so hey
wollen wir machen Comedy bisschen witzig
aber früher auch schon mal gemacht hat
sich gut ergeben haben wir weiter
gemacht warum soll man wegschmeißen und
äh dieses Album jetzt zwar einfach meine
Entscheidung ich hatte Lust einfach das
zu machen jetzt mit dem Status kann ich
mir das erlauben
gibst du vorher nicht gemacht wenn du
nicht diesen Status erreicht hast ja ein
Album so ein Markt bringen und so eine
Aufgabe das ging jetzt besser oder
leichter was hat sie erleichtert ja klar
ich bin jetzt etwas bekannter mich
kennen die Leute und ich kann jetzt
sowas bringen und ich also ich kann gute
Musik jetzt auch beweisen ich kann den
Leuten meine Musik zeigen damals wenn
ich etwas auf Youtube hochgeladen habe
aber vielleicht eine Einwohner hat
tausend kriegst gehabt nein jetzt geht's
bisschen besser ganz ganz genau ja und
wenn ich mir die Texte so anhöre das
geht ja auch in der andere Richtung also
es ist erstmal natürlich keine Parodie
aber es ist auch sehr ernsthaft es ist
eben nicht ich sag mal was jetzt
vielleicht Gangster im Titel naheliegen
würde dass du deine Herkunft vielleicht
Preis und ich war ein dicker Gangster
und sondern es geht mehr in die Richtung
hey ich bin ernsthaft und denke mal
darüber nach was er macht
so sieht's aus ist das was was dir
gefehlt hat in der app-szene ja das hat
mir auf jeden Fall gefehlt weil
die Musik ist keine Ahnung auf jeden
Fall ist irgendwie jeder rappt das
gleiche jeder rappt über Drogen und
Kilos und blablub was er da gemacht hat
und das hören sich kleine Kinder an ne
und
es ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlimm es
ist immer noch Musik also wenn jetzt
jemand sagt hey ich habe kilok heißt das
nicht dass die ganzen Kinder anfangen zu
Drogen zu nehmen aber das ist halt Rap
das das gehört natürlich auch dazu aber
bei mir geht's jetzt halt ein bisschen
anders ich sag jetzt auch nicht dass die
Blumen pflücken sollen oder so ein
Scheiß ne aber ich ähm z.B das dass man
mit Drogen nicht zu tun haben soll und
cool zu sein oder was auch immer das ist
andere Wege gibt und ja also ich habe
auch nie was mit Drogen zu tun gehabt
trotzdem bin ich gerne weiter okay was
ist für dich denn was macht ein Kohl
das macht einen cool man muss was im
Kopf haben erstmal wenn du wenn man was
im Kopf hat dann dann dann dann kann man
schon mal arbeiten dann kann man auf
jeden Fall schon mal etwas erreichen
etwas machen man muss standhaft sein
natürlich man muss seinen Mann stehen
was immer auch passiert
cool was heißt cool wenn du wenn du was
erreicht hast wo du wo du deine Eltern
zeigen kannst mama Papa guck mal was
geschafft habe und diesen Stolz drauf
das ist cool okay wie kommt also warum
siehst warum glaubst es ist bei anderen
eben sind eher Drogen cool und hassen
hier in weiß nicht was warum
ist das bei dir nie so angekommen warum
hast du den nicht nachgefert Drogen war
bei mir sowieso immer ein No-Go also ich
habe Drogen genommen
meine Brüder auch nicht also keiner von
uns nimmt irgendwelche Drogen oder hat
irgendwie irgendwelche Drogen probiert
also ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben
Joint geraucht oder so kann man
vielleicht jetzt nicht glauben aber ist
so Drogen verabscheue ich richtig auch
im Album wenig das oft dass das nicht
meine Sache ist ich so mit Drogen habe
ich nichts am Hut gehabt ich habe früher
paar Sachen gemacht aber
keine Drogen okay und wie kommt das also
ist es ist das Erziehung oder hast du im
Freundeskreis Erfahrungen gemacht die
dir gesagt haben nee Erziehung auf jeden
Fall Nummer eins also mein Vater hat
mich strengerzogen mein Vater hat mich
gerade erzogen meine Brüder haben immer
drauf aufgepasst auch ne dass ich sauber
bleibe ich war immer mit denen also ich
konnte nichts Falsches machen
und Freundeskreis auch ganz sauber also
mein Freundeskreises mit denen ich
früher vielleicht gibt's eins zwei
Freunde mit dem ich früher war die jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen weggekommen sind
aber 90% aller meiner Freunde sind immer
noch bei mir und diesen genau wie ich
und die bleiben so standhaft wie ich was
ist das Rezept um dabei zu bleiben also
um dann so abzudriften
oder ja was heißt Rezept man muss halt
mit den Leuten richtigen Leuten
unterwegs sein man muss auch passen mit
wem man unterwegs ist man soll den es
gibt viele Freunde klar aber man soll
halt drei vier Leute haben mit denen man
immer ist und ähm ich kann nur den
kleinen Kids da draußen sagen wenn euch
jemand was anbietet oder probieren keine
Ahnung haut ihm das Ding weg
den Joint oder was auch immer das ist
nicht cool